hello reject nation I'm Greg Elbe I am
John I Mary Perry Nemiroff from the very
Nemiroff channel also from Collider
video so I've asked to be part of our
Snowdown faction since I think our
faction fell apart I just told you I'm
really hot in 20 right now and you bring
up Schmo down and always stress me bit
more yeah now I'm hearing they're hot
and sweaty alright guys well we're going
to watch the trailer for the death of
Stalin Joseph Stalin my favorite
dictator as well as everyone else's here
I am NOT a major history of up on Russia
and communism during this time but a lot
of people are saying to check this
trailer yeah just so you know Matt
Lyle's this is your page for the day
shoutout video we will do it after the
reaction I have a message to get to you
man all smiles for Matt Lyles being mr.
fiducial
[ __ ] off before you go to spoke to our
general secretary is lying in a puddle
of indignities to do well I want to make
speeches myself a student no problem
technically yes practically what an
[ __ ] he would have ended it I think
as one all those in favor carry you man
I'm asleep
we would say this before if you can
mobilize that seems to be me you little
[ __ ]
Arisa started we need to stop eating
together a plan
how come you run soft at the same time
[Music]
and look this may go I'll [ __ ] up anyone
who gets in my way
[Music]
make sure you see they're killing them
in the process
leave the rest to you need your help in
Africa conversation threatening to do
harm or obstructing the new Presidium in
the process of what give your focus
hahahahaha I think I think I can open a
waistcoat oh heavens they never let any
harm come to you and they've got the
signal stuff like not oh Jesus Christ
Rococo sir I'll take a [ __ ] on aura no
you do not start walking
[Music]
okay take a breath right now
[Music]
you know all of you
- to my Russian ass don't worry nobody's
gonna get killed I promise you put an
end
I was not expecting that at all what an
interesting approach to this historical
piece it kind of feels a little bit like
a hybrid lives of like Wes Anderson
meets Christopher Guest a little bit I
think it changes farcical quality yeah
Oh totally it looks funny it looks
really funny it was pretty funny my mom
I mean obviously my mind immediately
went to in the loop which I surprisingly
enjoy not yeah normally that's not my
kind of film and not something I
gravitate towards but I like that one so
I assume I'm gonna like this I hope this
doesn't sound too mean but so one thing
I kept thinking about that entire
trailer is how disturbed I am by how
Steve Buscemi looks right now I know
maybe that there's maybe there's some
makeup there to make him look like how
many needs to look for that role but
you're so old well they gave the
following movies that I love him in I
don't it just makes me feel old and it
scares me it is odd to see him with just
like that regular like balding sort of
hair stages Jamie have you always look
lately guys no please just come on old
now yeah they're creepy yes regular for
you you know you don't need to freak out
Perry you look great right now don't
really know the right thing and don't
compare yourself with Steve Bishop
here's something you need Oh Jeffrey
Tambor looks awesome but even his seeds
reminded me like I feel like them
watching a scene of Arrested Development
the way it's shot with a handheld and
the type of banter that they're doing I
guess I'm not that familiar with the
story that takes place of the death of
Stalin the dis loosely is quite a unique
approach to be taking to it I wonder if
this will have any controversial type of
whiplash with us of the word backlash
backlash yeah that's the word I don't
know if we will you know we're kind of
having us
Timon Russia right now these kinds of
movies always do but like that's the
point in getting something like this and
telling the story this way is it not
necessarily sparked controversy but
discussion in conversation I was
surprised I mean this chair grab me kind
of immediately because I was not
expecting the tone that sort of pulled
me in from the get-go but I think Katz
is terrific
I'm almost excited now to see a
political story it'll probably you know
have some relevance to now as well but
anymore a farce to Gore you know with a
little more levity taking the comedic
angle is kind of nice you know right now
for telling an actual historical
political film so yeah that's definitely
what cooked me from the start
polity of the show even though we might
have nightmares restitution is a great
cast and everybody's playing like very
much for character it seems like from
Jeffrey Tambor to Steve Buscemi to Jason
Isaak piano like I'm excited to see him
he looks like a really fun character
watch like it and I like these kinds of
movies where when the tone surprises me
and the kind of characters the actors
are playing surprise me like that
usually get me and their comedic actors
who are a great with deadpan as well
okay before this video is done Matt
Lyle's this guy has been a part of our
patreon since the very beginning and he
plays the mouth where he can get a shout
out every month and Matt what I love
about you is we shout you out every
month you keep pledging and you never
reply back to any of the [ __ ]
messages I send you man I don't know
what you sound like I don't know what
you look like I don't even know how you
phrased sentences because you don't even
reply to the Inbox why are you here that
lot are you a robot I do not know we
want to know a bot you better tell me if
you are as a cool robot though I mean I
mean yeah I mean helps channel how so I
appreciate it but do the generous spot
I'm like wondering what what it who are
you who are you Matt side of the Dead
patreon so check it out subscribe for
the real rejects click that notification
bell dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram P Nemiroff on Twitter and I'm
Terry Nimrod YouTube and Perry Nemiroff
you can catch her on Collider videos as
well and in real life I'm a real living
breathing person